foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you yeah it's great to be back
with everybody it's been quite a while
since I've seen so many faces this is
this is awesome I love being here and I
love being here with you I like Tatu
said the name of my talk is our Python
and Tableau I love triangle
um some of you may recognize this goes
back to a few years ago we ran we did a
talk and we did an advertising campaign
around R and python a love story
and as I was getting ready for this talk
this title just seemed to write itself
and I was like this is just too good to
pass up on and then I started preparing
the talk and I was like love triangles
are kind of awful they don't end well
like nothing works out like this trying
to make an analogy between a love
triangle and like these three different
tools that I hope to illustrate work
really well together
um wasn't working out for me and so
we're gonna pivot a little bit and we'll
actually be talking a little bit we'll
be drawing some comparisons to music
today and and I hope that's okay
so to start we're going to listen to a
couple of audio samples from perhaps one
of the most famous pieces of classical
music you'll likely recognize it even if
you don't know the name or the composer
or anything like that we'll see if this
works um so we'll listen to this first
one here
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so some of you may recognize that that's
the beginning of Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony some of the most famous pieces
famous measures of classical music ever
heard now we're going to listen to one
more version of those same few measures
of music and then compare the two
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay same music Same notes
slightly different in the first case we
just have the piano and nothing against
the piano I'm a Pianist I have I've been
a piano since I was five years old I
love the piano but it can't quite
compare to the richness of a full
Symphony right as we add additional
musical instruments as we layer in
additional components the depth of the
music grows and we can hear that in in
the two examples we just looked at today
we're going to look at how we can do the
same with our analyzes if we start with
a basic Tableau dashboard how can we add
additional tools and bring additional
Technologies to that dashboard to add
additional depth of insight to what
we're delivering to our business users
here's kind of an example dashboard this
is a pretty straightforward data
exploration dashboard that allows a user
to explore a given data set I can choose
an x-axis I can choose a y-axis I can
exploit the relationship between two
features in this case this data set is a
collection of attributes from different
pieces of music different genres of
music different songs from those genres
how popular were they how danceable are
they how likable are they what the tempo
is things of that nature so I can create
comparisons between classical music and
Hip-Hop or instrumental music or
electronic music if I want to and a user
can come in here and explore and start
to determine their own insights and and
arrive at conclusions based on what
they're looking at in this data
now if we wanted to take this to another
level and add additional details to it
we might want to look to add some
machine learning capabilities here what
if we tried to predict the popularity of
a song based on different attributes and
and how could we evaluate the
effectiveness of different models we
might be using
to kind of illustrate this example I'm
actually going to turn to my son I have
a two-year-old son he just turned two a
couple days ago his name is Forest here
he is this picture was taken just before
I left and as you can tell from this
photo he's a bit random so we are going
to be training a random forest model
today
in R what this might look like is
something like this we'll bring in a
package like the ranger package and we
can write a simple function that takes
some input data X and Y trains a model
spits out the predicted values based on
the training data that we that we
supplied now for all the machine
learning experts in the audience this is
not a course on machine learning so
please recognize that this is perhaps a
bit overly simplistic but it should help
us highlight and understand how these
different components can all fit
together
if I wrote a function like this in R and
that I wanted that function to be
accessible to other tools right we're
gonna we're gonna ignore Tableau for a
moment and just say look I want some
generic other service to have access to
this thing that I wrote
the best and easiest way to do that in R
is using the plumber package and here's
an example of what that might look like
if I bring in the plumber package first
of all I have to bring the package into
my workspace and then all I need to do
is add a few special comments to my
script that indicate hey this should be
a an API that's listening for requests
from other services
it's very straightforward and easy to
use especially if I'm already used to
using r
now let's take that and make it a little
bit more specific let's say that instead
of just any generic service out there I
actually want this to be used from
within Tableau I want Tableau to be able
to submit data to this to this function
and I want this function to execute and
return the data back to Tableau well I
could write my own very unique API to do
that or I could use the plumber Tableau
package which handles a lot of the
specifics behind the scenes to make this
API work specifically with Tableau
workbooks and dashboards as you'll
notice again I've highlighted the
differences here between a traditional
plumber API and this new plumber Tableau
API and they're very minimal I bring in
the plumber Tableau package I had a few
additional comments that indicate what
type of data I'm expecting from Tableau
what type of data I'm going to be
returning to Tableau and then the most
significant piece is that piece there at
the bottom where I indicate that I'm
creating a tableau extension
if we do the same thing on the python
side we can bring in scikit-learn we
could Define a function that creates and
trains a random forest and again spits
out the predicted outcomes based on the
input data that we received
if I want to make this a generically
available service I could use a tool
like Fast API I can bring in the fast
API module I can define an app and then
I can Define routes on that app that are
functions that are listening for
incoming input
just like we saw on the r side with
plumber Tableau there's a new package
called Fast API Tableau that does the
same thing in fact it's maybe even a
little bit easier than what we saw in
the plumber Tableau side because all I
need to do is change import fast API to
import fast API Tableau and I need to
change my app instantiation instead of
saying it's a fast API app I now just
say it's a fast API Tableau app
everything else Remains the Same
now once I've developed these extensions
I might I might have used our studio
workbench to develop these I might have
developed these locally but once I've
developed them I need somewhere where
they can be hosted so that I can access
them from within Tableau the easiest
place to do that is our studio connect
and here's an example of what it looks
like when I've published these two
extensions onto rstudio connect
the first thing I'm going to look at is
I'm going to look at the python
extension that we built and once I come
in here you'll see that I have a nice
user interface that illustrates to
Tableau users exactly what they need to
do if they want to use this extension
there's also a nice feature for the
developer which will allow me to come in
here and test the API out make sure the
extension is doing what I wanted to do
does it take data appropriately does it
return the appropriate response does it
behave the way that I think it should
behave this is really nice because as a
an r or a python developer this means I
never have to open Tableau I can start
from the beginning and I can go all the
way through to a working functioning
extension of Tableau but I never have to
actually open Tableau to verify Its
Behavior
if we look at the r extension here's the
r extension we published we see a
similar thing we have a nice interface
that lets us know how to use this from
within Tableau and we'll take a look at
that implementation in just a moment and
I also have the ability like we saw on
the python side to test and verify the
behavior of this particular of this
particular extension I can copy I'll put
data from somewhere else I can drop it
in here and I can verify that this is in
fact returning the results that I would
expect it to be returning given the
function that I defined
now if we look at how to do this within
Tableau we've tried to make this as easy
as possible for somebody who maybe isn't
an r or python developer but is a
tableau user to be able to come in and
use an extension that has been shared on
a platform like rstudio connect
in that case the user might come in to
this particular page they'll highlight
and copy the usage section of the
documentation they'll move over into
Tableau create a new calculated field
give that calculated field some sort of
a name in this case we'll call this
random forest or something of that
effect and then paste in the the data
that they copied to the script that they
copied from the previous documentation
once this is copied in the only thing
that we need to do is we need to supply
the actual names of fields that we want
Tableau to supply to this extension in
this case I was very creative and so we
have x-axis and y-axis
but that allows us to Simply identify
what the X and Y variables are that
we're passing in to our underlying model
once this is done I can use the
calculated field I can drag it into my
workbook and use it just as I would any
other variable or feature within my data
set
so if we bring all of these different
components together now right we have
this original Tableau dashboard that
allows users to explore data Define X
and Y axes filter to specific genres of
music identify relationships between
these these different features that they
might be interested in looking at and
then we have these two new extensions
that we've developed both are training
random Forest models but one's done in
Python and one is done in R and they're
hosted on our studio connect
if we take a look at what if we take a
look at all these pieces put together we
might have something that looks like
this our original dashboard is up at the
top where users can still Define X and Y
axes investigate relationships between
different components within the data but
then down below we've added these two
new plots that indicate the residual
plots from our underlying random Forest
models that we trade on the left we see
our random forest model in r on the
right we see our random forest model in
Python and you'll see as I interact with
this particular dashboard these
everything is dynamic everything updates
as I make changes and adjustments to the
dashboard so if I choose to bring
electronic music into the mix I'll see
that first reflected in the plot up
above and then I'll see it also
reflected in the plots below as new data
once again this is a real-time
interaction so new data is being being
submitted from Tableau to these
extensions some sort of execution is
happening and then the results are being
transmitted right back into Tableau for
further analysis
now this use case is is a little bit
specific and the use case that we've
kind of focused on primarily here is I'm
in Tableau but I need to do something to
my data that Tableau can't do and in
many cases that might be like something
machine learning or machine learning
adjacent right I need to do some sort of
statistical procedure or analysis the
Tableau just isn't fully equipped to do
and and I've had good conversations with
people at Tableau that have that have
indicated to me look we're not we're not
trying to make Tableau a fully featured
statistical analysis engine and so these
extensions are the way in which we can
broaden the horizons of what Tableau is
capable of by allowing it to plug into
other tools that might be more effective
at certain tasks and we certainly might
all agree that R and python are two
tools very well suited to Common
statistical and machine learning tasks
there's another class of problems though
and that class of problems is
I have some data in Tableau and I have
in my mind some sort of visualization
that I want to do
but I can't do it where it's really
difficult and if you've ever worked with
Tableau I find myself in this position
pretty frequently where I can imagine
some sort of visualization and then I
find myself wishing there was some sort
of like ggplot Tableau integration thing
while we don't quite have that what we
do have is a package called shiny
tableau
shiny Tableau and I'm not going to go
through all of the details here I'm
going to provide links to the
documentation and things that you can
kind of explore on your own but shiny
Tableau allows you to define a custom
shiny application that creates a unique
extension for a tableau workbook what
this looks like is and on the left I
have this there's a specific manifest
file that you write when you create
these extensions there's some Nuance to
how this gets put together and if you're
familiar with shiny it will feel
comfortable and familiar to you but if
it's you know if you're not quite
familiar with shiny that's it's a good
idea to start with shiny first and then
look at at shiny Tableau as a second
option
um but there's this manifest file that I
create that defines the extension and
some attributes of it and when I run
that shiny application or when I publish
that shiny application to somewhere like
rstudio connect what I end up with is
this page on the right this doesn't look
like any sort of shiny application
you've likely seen before because
there's nothing really interactive here
instead what I have is a prompt to
download some sort of file
so what I do is I download that file
locally and then if I'm using Tableau
desktop I can import that file directly
into Tableau desktop if I'm using
something like Tableau online I would
need to put that file in a location
where I can read it from my Tableau
online or Tableau server environment
so if we bring all this together and
take it once more from the top here's
what that might look like here's the
existing dashboard that I have with my
iron python extensions operating here on
the bottom and if I want to bring this
shiny Tableau extension is and what I
need to do is drag an extension onto my
dashboard navigate to that file that I
downloaded locally so here we'll see
that I select the file that was
downloaded from that shiny application
once that's downloaded I then need to
configure the extension itself and these
are all components that you can adjust
and set up when you define the shiny
Tableau extension I'll come in here I'll
select the data that I want this
extension to be reading from and then
I'll select the values that I want
Tableau to pass to this specific
extension
in this case what we're going to do once
we've finished this is we'll have a nice
density plot over here on the right hand
side that demonstrates the density of
everything along the y-axis and I could
do the same thing to create a density
plot along the x-axis as well which
might be something that I want to give
me a better understanding of the shape
of my data especially when I have so
many data points that I'm considering
like I have in this particular
visualization
one other thing that's worth mentioning
that I haven't brought up to this point
is the fact that again we have both our
and python extensions operating as part
of the same tablet workbook
our studio connect is the only endpoint
that supports this idea of both R and
python extension simultaneously in the
same workbook it is something more
traditional like tab higher our serve
you would be restricted only to to
python execution or only to our
execution
but given the work that we've done with
the folks at Tableau and and the work
that we've done internally with our
studio connect our studio connect can
host our excuse me our extensions and
python extensions side by side and they
can be leveraged from the same Tableau
environment alongside things like shiny
Tableau extensions as well
so what does this all mean going back to
our music analogy the idea here is we
can use the right combination of tools
for the job and we can deliver a
symphony of insight more than just a
piano solo we can deliver something that
astounds and astonishes our end users
now is this necessary every time it's
not I have a six-year-old daughter who
just had her first piano recital and it
was exactly what it needed to be she
didn't need to be playing the violin and
and the TR and the trumpet and
everything all at once the piano recital
was enough
and it's up to us as the data scientists
as the analysts to decide what level of
insight is the appropriate level for the
analysis that we're doing
it's important to understand that we
have a whole host of tools like JJ kind
of alluded to in his talk this morning
we continue to look at this ecosystem
and look for ways in which we can
participate in the broad scientific
Computing ecosystem and that includes
tools like Tableau and the Integrations
that we've done there
if you're interested in learning more
there's some resources here there's a
GitHub repository that has several
different examples of how these
different extensions can work with
different Tableau workbooks and things
like that and you can learn from those
examples the slides and all the content
from this talk will be made available on
GitHub shortly after I've kind of
finished everything up today and finally
I just want to say thank you it's been
great being back in person and if
there's any questions we can take those
now
foreign
[Music]